this episode answer the internet's
brought to you by manscape more on that
in a minute stay tuned to the very end
to get your promo code for a discount
i'm so scared that one was intentional
[ __ ] you guys you're not allowed to come
to the island with me honestly
and i'm gonna be you're gonna be there
with like a bunch of crunch
and die immediately and i'm gonna have
so many tools
my name is carly aquilino and i'm here
to answer the internet
if you could bang any celebrity but
you'd have to make a sex tape with them
that would go viral would you do it
dwayne the rock johnson
yeah and it's going viral you're out
there mom and grandma and everybody sees
it
[Applause]
if you were born with action figure
hands stuck in the same position forever
what position would your hands be in
um probably like this because i feel
like i embarrassingly do this
all the time that's your move yeah you
got your hands right
yeah i would just be like that yeah you
know for sure
smoking yeah all of it i could do
anything like this
you could put it there smoking this girl
just takes two
wait he was like well i need a fist to
survive and
a hand to dig you're like no be like
not the other one well another one
really wants your legs to be frozen too
i want my arms to be like this i don't
want to even be able to move my arms
i want them just only in this position
what movie most recently made you cry
oh the movie i always cry to is the lion
king
every time i hate scar what opening
scene at the end of it
the end no the end for sure i mean it's
so sad
he's hanging and then that's not the end
that's the beginning
that's not the opening scene either
you're both wrong that's towards the
beginning
yeah yeah yeah when is it when mufasa
well it's when mufasa dies but
yeah you're right because then simba
gets older you're right yeah
scar is does he have that bad boy
right he has that bad boy five he does
that's my voice
if you could be any character from a tv
show who would it be
we're gonna get back to carly's answer
in a second but first feitelberg's got
you covered it's the answer is easy it's
frank reynolds in the quarantine episode
because hair is disgusting it's where
all the germs are kept no one wants to
suck your dick if it's hairy
no one wants to eat your ass if it's
hairy you need to use a [ __ ] manscape
trimmer get the lawnmower 4.0 and
everything else you need to stay smooth
smell good and keep your partner happy
use promo code internet20 at
manscape.com to get twenty percent off
fran drescher and the nanny jack
i already are i mean if i wish um
if you could be a master at one of the
four bases of sex
but you'd be below average in every
other base which one would you choose
i guess i would be a master at kissing
because then you trick people
into thinking that you're good at the
other stuff and then you can kind of
just
not be good at the other stuff and it's
too late
like you got to get in the door i would
just i would rather be good at that
because then it's kind of like oh gotcha
[Laughter]
usually people end up there they don't
usually get there on their own though
you were just cut right to the chase you
you figured it out pretty fast no i've
thought about it before i have i'm like
what
can i do the least work possible would
you rather live your life
as is or be a billionaire but you have
to blow a dude every day i would of
course be a billionaire that blows
dudes every day
oh it's supposed to be okay yeah but
also no of course what if it's this like
so
let's say it's like you're almost like
you're not marrying the guy but you're
getting the money because of him what if
he's like an old
like would you like that's great i would
love to blow billy gates every day
a billionaire what about a millionaire
yeah i probably would honestly no taxes
taken out
then that's what's important that would
definitely be and then
so just think about on day like one
thousand and bill gates is like
here yeah he's got his glasses i also
would love that
i would love that now i would do it
i was just gonna say i would do it for
free gates is a single guy do you think
you would like date
okay yeah for sure i would like i'm
looking for him everybody yeah
but it's like would you really be bill
gates's girlfriend would you want
bill gates like honestly yes
of course i would no he's like my
soul mate i love him am i not supposed
to think he's hot i don't understand
what about bezos is it specifically
gates or is it um
okay so if it were like [ __ ] marry kill
bezos gates
zuckerman remember remember that like
photo that came out of zuckerberg
like surfing and he had a a juicy ass
i was like okay
he also said that he wore that much
sunscreen
right he looked like a ghost trying to
blend
in
yeah he had a donkey for sure so where
are you okay so i would
kill zuckerberg i would
marry i would marry bill and i would
[ __ ] jeff yeah
can you still go to your barber if he's
very racist
oh my god the picture on this uh
in your case you know if i were going to
a hairdresser i think i would feel too
weird especially because girls when you
go get a haircut you get your hair
colored or something you're there for
like
hours so it would be like somebody's
trying to initiate you into a cult
i wouldn't be able to do it but your
hair is white but my hair looks good
everyone's like oh my god your hair is
beautiful
right like you're known as like the
comic with the best hair because when
you when you're in the blowout thing
yeah you're just sitting there reading
your mind
[Laughter]
i don't think i'd be able to do it i
would have her train somebody else
and be like nobody but you yourself know
in your heart
i don't know it's too long of a time to
sit there
it took too long for you to answer that
you're racist um would you rather live
with your parents for the rest of your
life
or always
or always use toilet paper as napkins
this is hard doesn't mean anything about
that [ __ ] bunch of crunch
and popcorn oh yeah because it's not
just roll with you you're in public
yeah and it's written it's never
the double plot it's like one ply yeah
yeah yeah it's the bad guy
it's like hospital toilet paper um
it's like you know what i'm saying that
like cheap like scott
you see through right away let alone
right and then you have to use that as a
napkin which means you're always going
to have like
balled up um
where you gonna live with mama ack yeah
i think i would do the napkin i would do
toilet paper snapkins yeah
i just feel like i need my space you
know
what three items can that can fit in a
fanny pack would you choose to bring
with you to a deserted island
see now this is like a trick question
because if you bring your
phone you're not gonna be able to charge
it right because you're on a deserted
island
so you need survival kit type things in
your fanny pack
so you would need for the most part you
have your brakes there's electricity
no no no no electricity but you don't
have to like
these are a little bit so i could bring
stuff that i need to charge
no no no no i can't bring stuff
or something like that it can be like i
would never bring medicine i would die
on the island i don't care all right
like give me an infection
no yeah you're not getting electricity
not getting electricity okay i would
bring
a fire starter i watch a lot of naked
and afraid
i would bring a fire starter i would
bring
um
you know people are like people would
say like i would bring a compass i don't
care
and i don't know how to read a compass i
don't care where i'm at really so
yeah i don't think that would help me
yeah accomplish
one of the easiest things in the world
to read no i don't understand what it
means because you want to know why
everywhere i'm facing to me is north
i'm just kind of like north and then if
i'm this way it's north
and i'm all good like the world revolves
around
when people are on 14th street and you
look at 13th street you think that's
north
whichever way i'm facing is north and
when people have the balls to say to me
oh meet me on the north west okay first
of all are you christopher columbus
like don't talk to me like that ever
again say i'm outside of burger king and
i'll know where you're at
it's not put like is this science class
so definitely not a compass um
in a fanny pack probably honestly
what would be another really helpful
thing fire starter you gotta
you need some type of a tie like a tie
like a rope right to make knots so you
can build a shelter
i don't understand why everybody's kind
of judging
my answer everything they're like
which is in summer camp i'm making this
i just love
most people are like my favorite like
candy
my vibrator and like sunscreen no well
why would
i thought this was about the island
being deserted i thought this was about
survival why would i bring [ __ ] candy
i'm gonna eat it in three seconds
a spear
[ __ ] you guys you're not allowed to come
to the island with me honestly
and i'm gonna be you're gonna be there
with like a bunch of crunch
and die immediately and i'm gonna have
so many
over tools how much money would it take
for you to give up your favorite food
for the rest of your life
it's hard because my favorite food is
just bread
so it's just bread so all breads like
but like so sandwiches are out burgers
are out that's a lot of things
um how often do you just sit there and
eat bread all the time
what kind of breath any kind um
i like honestly i like just like a loaf
of bread like a baguette
classy a baguette i mean i know what
you're trying to say but that's not how
you say that
how do you say it you're from france
what
[Music]
what is it um i would say baguette but i
also think that she might be more right
that they they play like in the baguette
it's a it's a baguette it depends on if
you're from france or not i think
yeah i i think this is the first time i
i was in french class that's how they
pronounced yeah
wow
very embarrassing very embarrassing
you guys no it's fine no some of us are
from france and some aren't
and that's fine how do you say uh in
nintendo's a little italian plumber
red guy what do you how do you say his
name mario he's a real one
what i get [ __ ] roasted every day why
what would it be
oh mario okay that right that's like
very classy mario
yeah if you had to watch your biggest
enemy [ __ ] the girl of your dreams or
the guy in your dreams
in order for you to marry him would you
do it of course
my biggest enemy is gwyneth paltrow
so she could [ __ ] brad pitt yeah she
already has it's all good
so really think about though then you'd
be watching like let's say
rekindled and you're watching them you
know cause x sex sometimes where it's
like yeah but it never lasts it doesn't
matter
they've already done it in your head
forever it's like remember that yeah
right but i would be like okay i get to
marry you
that would be the best i mean what a
treat have fun
i don't care it's brad pitt if you got
ten thousand dollars a day
for every day you didn't masturbate how
many days could you last i could go the
rest of my life
ten thousand dollars a day that's fine
with me and it's just masturbating you
could still have sex
see that's a that's a female i know yeah
guys it's like yeah we can but can we
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah 100 what if you couldn't get off
what about
no getting off well so it's reality i
think
like so what's your current drowning
right
[Laughter]
i think i would wait so if i did
then i would stop getting the money and
you can't resume i would go the rest
i could go the rest of my life i am
saying let's stack this bread
and i don't need it i don't need it i
promise you
i'm fine it's fine no i would
no i would be okay i would go at least
until i saved up like
i'm i would go in lease until i saved up
like millions of dollars
i would have the nicest [ __ ] i just like
that's really all that's now she's
making money or she's approaching
right she hasn't come in five years he
hasn't come since
right that would be the loophole like
never having an orgasm again would
probably be harder than never
like okay
i would still be able to save up
millions of dollars i really
feel that way i feel like what would we
reach like can i tell you it's really
just
yeah really i mean no being realistic
i think like one weekend i'd be like
how much is that ten thousand yeah see i
just would be like okay cool i'm just
gonna
like jeff bezos who like this way you
don't have to try and get with bill
gates
ten thousand a day is a lot so i would
do that myself
all right thanks to carliacolino for
answering the internet make sure you
leave a comment below to see more comics
entertainers and celebrities that you
want to see on the show
make sure you subscribe and hit the bell
icon
to set notifications
[Music]
i hate this
good good all right my hair is so
[ __ ] fast